[Music]
three two one action
god I love you hey guys welcome back to
off-the-record we talked about what
today we're gonna be talking about
something talked about breakups I do too
but first repping me damn I'm sorry you
interrupted the brand deal tip Joe are
you gonna say something about sponsors
yes we have to sponsors are yelling
going on wait before we talk about your
guys break up we got two sponsors yes we
have two sponsors and they're keeping us
alive Thank You Roman and upstart first
Roman here we go
erectile dysfunction is more common than
you think 52% of men over 40 experienced
erectile today
penis erection happenings yeah that's
true but even worse about 75% of those
guys don't seek treatment that's why
Roman has made it easy to chat with a
doctor thank God thank God all of you
are thinking these guys they can think
in Roman right now okay with Roman you
can get medical care for Edie if
appropriate from the comfort and privacy
of your own home but
yeah that's pretty awesome comes over
and checks your pecker yeah service
coming to your house the doctor do you
send dick pics that's the only good day
no don't send dis dick pics but you can
handle everything online in a convenient
discreet manner right getting started is
simple just go to get Roman comm slash
OTR that's four off the record baby and
complete and online visit if your doctor
decides that treatment would be
appropriate they can prescribe genuine
medication that can be delivered in
discreet packaging size dick shaped
boxes yeah it'll be right to your door
with free two-day shipping erectile
dysfunction can be tough to tackle but
it's really important to get checked out
with Roman it's easy to connect with a
doctor I think this is [ __ ] awesome
because if I got erectile dysfunction I
would not go to the doctor yes you would
go
you get Roman calm okay and our second
beautiful wonderful sponsor is upstart
upstart is the first artificial
intelligence lending platform designed
to improve affordable credit I need this
I need this now okay upstart goes beyond
the traditional FICO score when
assessing your creditworthiness they
reward you based on your education and
job history in the form of a smarter
interest rate what can I get with she
has a man golden bat credit how do you
balance the two that's good yeah so
upstart believes you're more than just
your credit score our ha they believe in
you and they understand that they make
it fast simple and easy to check your
rate in just a few minutes without
affecting your credit score I need that
the best part once the loan is approved
most people get their funds the very
next business day that's the next day
any money now that's someone else's line
yeah
hey I butchered it on purpose I know
said only money they should probably use
up star-nosed okay over 200,000 people
have used up start to pay off credit
cards student loans fund their wedding
or to make a large purchase catering
good really this video is not about you
okay free yourself from the burden of
high interest credit card debt by
consolidating everything into one
monthly payment with up start yup and I
just recently did a whole talk on credit
cards and debit and all that stuff so
this is pretty awesome
so see why upstart is ranked number one
in their category with over 300
businesses on Trustpilot and hurry to up
Starcom slash record to find out to find
out how low your up start rate is
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes that won't affect your credit
Bing Bing Bing
and again this one more time just to
make sure calm / record yay thanks
sponsor links in the description yeah
yes did you get your dick fixed and your
credit fix oh that's two things that
girls want mm-hmm
nice big in a nice credit yeah speaking
of dicks and credit goes how's it going
your sex lives you know what now that
it's not existent and you know this [ __ ]
we haven't [ __ ] in ages but before
enough sir then if you guys don't know
what we're talking about and you want to
see go to my channel please no go to
just right side you're on
yeah yeah and each side will see which
one gets clicked more all right views in
his chapter on Christmas with I know
that Jess really agrees with us so we
broke up we broke up and what we didn't
talk about is how we broke up and it all
actually went down I know homing in our
living room living room sage now thanks
a lot anyone to blame you guys could
blame the [ __ ] out of Steve and Nicky
woman Nicky Nicky was always trying to
keep us together you Eve on the other
hand listen I wanted you guys to be
happy and I don't think and you guys
have not been happy together for a long
[ __ ]
that's very true and it was the only one
rooting for us like no Steve was not
rooting for us he was really forced to
fail us what I'm saying your
independence and your happiness through
your independence I can't wait to
rooting is hurting yep not get married
for you guys okay together and everyone
I know that feeling yeah you were
rooting them too for them to find
happiness through staying together but
since they could not find happiness
through staying together we just root
for their happiness in general even if
it has to be you know a Nikki told me
she said cuz me and Joe were talking
about possibly getting married and I
announced
just to the girls and she said that her
and Steve were like oh my god we're
gonna have to schedule an intervention
because they bad friend
we have to stop we're gonna stop the
wedding we're gonna stop the wedding I
was like I'll bring a [ __ ] blue box
and then bidet is anyone have any
interruptions and I hold up a blue box
and I don't [ __ ] do it
I had no idea until I actually broke up
with and then they told me I was like
what the [ __ ] well yeah we were gonna
say anything were you guys gonna wait
until that's actually like happy we
didn't wait though I talked to him the
Monday after you guys talked about
getting married and I was like I don't
know I'm Earl
oh that's cool I would have waited I
always knew these intentions yeah I
would have waited for when the priest
said doesn't anybody have objections so
we can have a good content honestly you
guys really and you would have been like
wait don't do it have a priest at my
wedding or whatever it's the father
David basically maybe was officiating
the wedding we know you wouldn't be
wearing what everyone would have been
like wait not a chance
but there-there was a lot of backstory
is not like Steve was just like
immediately off the bat like [ __ ] you
guys I hope you don't know you don't
like dicks a lot of facts there's a lot
of akut protects Steve yeah like what
led up because there's a lot of like
maybe we'll break up stuff that happened
yeah a lot no I mean you guys were right
though you know I live for being bunch
of hating-ass [ __ ] intervention I
know your guys like you Steven icky as
friends like seeing that and like seeing
the outcome and like seeing how like
their happiness um was like your main
intention that makes me look at myself
and think like your selfish ass [ __ ] I
had friend cuz I see that [ __ ] I was
just trying to like be there for I don't
know like trying to see if it could work
out cuz you guys came to like to me a
lot because I was struggling a lot with
a fake our relationship was pretty bad
but luckily we've managed to get out of
that and every down there's always that
up and yeah I mean and just kind of
thought you could help them find it I
really thought I mean who knows right it
could have gone anywhere I think it just
there's so many factors though there's
timing there's like maturity there's can
we solve this now personal like what
we're going through at the
there's just so many [ __ ] but you guys
didn't have a relationship you had like
a friendship basically and so it was
about recognizing reality and not about
like trying to force something that
wasn't happening like you guys knows how
to be like the relationship guy he's
just like oh you can hang out with me
it's cool I think you guys drained each
other more than you like lifted each
other was the bottom line and that when
that happens over a long period of time
it's really hard to like salvage that
those wounds and you could do a lot of
work and maybe it maybe you can salvage
it and it works but if you guys were
trying really hard and nothing was
working and so it'll it just seemed like
you know it would be almost forcing
something if you guys got married like
it would be like trying to fix their
with marriage and I don't think things
really get fixed that's why I said you
guys like to like gay best friends
because it's like you guys were about to
get married to each other like to try to
make it work you tuck in their usual and
you're not like romantic and you're not
like the building blocks of a
relationship we're not there so that's
why when he brought it up and he's like
we could just do it for tax purposes and
I was like okay cool the thinest oh
that's so nice and then like it wasn't
just for tax purposes it was to show
commitment I know it wasn't like wasn't
an actual like proposer like I want to
marry you like yeah yeah it was just
like yeah we can do this yeah and you
know it'll really help out with our text
too and then so like a week later I
think we got into an argument and I was
just like okay you know what what the
[ __ ] I can't I don't want this and it's
not right and I don't want to sign some
marriage papers and then cuz I'm like oh
man there's a huge chance it's not gonna
work out and it's gonna be like oh I
dare you to take your money and I'm like
nope not doing it yeah yeah for sure
yeah so how do you guys feel now it's
been how long has talking amazing yeah
like okay it sucks because we still live
together right and I miss you like I
missed like I just told her the other
day like we're I'm meeting a little
Tokyo we live there and like we're still
it's weird cuz we're I don't I don't
it's not like a breakup where I lost her
yeah she's still a part of my company
she's in my proximity she's your Saran
she's my friend I care about her deeply
everything
good yeah but that but the frustration
in the baggage and all the stuff that I
didn't like in the relationship is now
gone so I have all the great parts of
her yeah so up now it's kind of like is
it gonna work cuz all those things all
those negative feelings are gone right
and then she does something and I'm like
yeah this is the best decision in my
whole entire life like what we barely
even see each other no no just like just
the way you guys operate
yeah just whip cracking and it's just
normal things speak the same language
yeah yeah yeah not like you did anything
wrong but it's literally like the signs
of the friction or the signs of the
baggage and it's like oh this is why we
can't be together we're just different
people different energy like do you feel
like us like still living in the same
place is hard for you then cuz I no not
at all we barely even see each other no
no they're just reminders because okay
so maybe I worded it wrong but what it
is is just things that remind me that
this could have led into a fight if we
were together I'm glad that we no longer
take that path anymore cuz it's like
let's say like I didn't move my car in
the morning and then like you you're
you're like rushing or whatever before I
would have probably got mad at you for
rushing me or whatever but now I'm like
okay you gotta go you gotta go
I'm waking up at 6 a.m. to workout yeah
and then like you're like can you be
quiet and I'm like I would have got
angry at you but I'm just reading it
like well so it's you being problematic
both have a perspective that I
understand both right and we just don't
see eye to eye yeah we were talking on
the break about how like you just got to
find somebody that's like your best
friend yeah I was talking about living
with exes who I felt like I couldn't be
100% myself around I couldn't like loud
and be like do all the things that I'd
wanted to do like I was you know
preparing for auditions and I'd want to
like you know get out of my body and I
would want to like do noises and all
this weird [ __ ] and I couldn't do it
when I was living with them but with
Steve I've always felt like I could be
the weirdest version of myself
he completely loves and supports it and
I feel like a better version of myself
like trapped in and I remember you
saying like how your lose
yourself and I'm not letting you be you
know who you were you lost your sense of
identity same with me you know and I
think just that environment that we
created we were bringing each other down
so things like that like I think oh you
know yeah once we're not officially
together it helps me think clear like oh
[ __ ] this is better for both of us you
can grow and become you know the best
version of guess without the feeling of
like am I being the best boy girlfriend
and all that stuff
you're like scared of getting into
fights and stuff I know that was a huge
pressure or expectations and now there's
no pressure so it's like I get the
coolest part of all like you know she
still works as a friend all that stuff
and now I could joke around and blame to
the viewers like why you still want me
to be in JK cuz that might be confusing
to most normal people who are like you
can't still be around your ex like that
like oh well I am a control freak and I
love to just trap people so no I'm just
kidding honestly I think get up so we
went through a lot of I feel very twenty
members this is my first episode of the
day you guys I just got here and this is
nuts it's thinking here trap your ass
should've brought wine got a big goal I
just woke up you guys okay gone [ __ ] Oh
teasing you I was testing you guys
titties at like 9:00 in the morning come
on and then went back to bed moving on
my normally I would ask what that means
but this can't be about to know what it
means go ahead go on no it can't be it
can't be Gibby no more kiddies
yeah well anyways maybe tease for the
thumbnail though cuz that'll help that's
where I'm keeping you rap video on I
know just cleavage how about just dude
no but um well yeah I mean known as he
just just just as a friend just as
someone who like just someone on the JK
team there's no other person within JK
that can run JK news the way that Jess
can run why aren't you hiring outside
what I'm trying to ask all the questions
that people probably why not hire I'm
too lazy okay no no because it's like if
you've got someone badass why the [ __ ]
would you get theirs yeah we're cool the
only thing is we're not romantic anymore
so why waste that you know that's
[ __ ] awesome also all of my work I
can do remotely so it really doesn't
matter like I don't have to see you
every single day it's where it's like
affecting your psyche or anything as
we're breaking up and it's moving on
like I can do everything from y'all
follow-up question yeah honest question
what happens when one of you starts
dating somebody and you're still working
at the company how does that feel and
how does that interaction and all I mean
personally I'm not putting my
relationships in the public anymore hmm
so also like maybe for the podcast
I might start talking about dating but
that's not gonna be for several months
yeah your minds not even on dating yeah
so I feel like the thing would be like
that we're gonna talk about it before
anything ever like I'm not gonna
blindside him with oh this is [ __ ] my
new boy John you know like I'm not gonna
do that and I would think that he would
do that too that's actually my dad's
name I just that was the first male name
that I'd any issues are you sad no that
was just the first name that came up is
there gonna be like an underlying
competition of who's gonna go out there
and get one first no I don't I really
hope that we can both offer myself as a
wingwoman to the both of you no Gina you
have to pick a side two guys for the
guys and the girls are for the girls how
it works on JK apparently especially
party I think we took it a little far
though okay follow up follow leave Joe
didn't answer hashtag get just laid no
no I think as long as were we're living
together it's a bit weird yeah I'm not
gonna do anything all right yeah and
it's too fresh yeah it's it's it's to me
it's it's I'm not even thinking about
sex or anything like I'm just thinking
about work and how I sense of myself
yeah and I'm just trying to like dive
into creativity and I
felt like there's a huge void in me that
hasn't really expressed myself fully
through just fun and comedy in a lot of
ways so that part of myself I'm really
excited to get back into I've been
writing and doing all that stuff so
that's really consuming me like that's
about three or four months or something
well I don't know cuz you know I'm like
a [ __ ] paper bag blowing in the wind
you know like I don't know what's gonna
happen like just is your American Beauty
but like the games just the bag itself
like yeah I'm just really used to have a
40 in it like I guess I don't know if
you mentioned this in your video but
like what plans do you have for yourself
since you guys do live together like are
you because are you guys gonna move out
yeah what yeah the plan is like I'm
gonna get a full-time job because I can
actually do most of this stuff in the
evenings and weekends and like it's not
like a 40 a 50 hour a week job to like
run this channel so I'm gonna get a
full-time job more of a corporate type
of job and then I'm gonna look for a
place I'm gonna have to like work for a
few weeks save up some money look for a
place like so the whole process could
take four to eight weeks are there still
any um like tears are you guys sad yeah
we had about a good two weeks Bobby yeah
I cried in a Church's Chicken parking
lot while eating chicken it was terrible
well they just come back two nights ago
I pulled over to get chicken and then I
cried on Tuesday we cried a couple of
times together that was uh probably
before we filmed that together like we
just hung out and like each other's
rumor in the living room or something
and talked for a long time and kind of
cried it out and I still feel sad
that's okay in the parking lot it was it
was really greasy yeah it was really
good cheap you're wiping your eyes there
was the grease crunch it if you clench
your butthole it stops you from girl
works I all right what's the phone so
you don't gag while sucking dick okay oh
and then you home see to get the yeah
yeah yeah so I mean I still have a lot
of emotions about it yeah I just don't
show it because like I don't want to cry
on camera yeah well endings are sad even
if it's for the better it's just endings
are [ __ ] sad man like especially if
you're sentimental I just like even like
leaving a job or whatever is [ __ ]
it's a chapter when I move out of the
house I kind of like tear up and like
touch the walls before because they're
all on a [ __ ] movie Marie Kondo says
to do that when you're cleaning your
house to Stu touch the middle of the
floor and then be like tell me what you
want to keep the goose duck yeah yeah
and I love so I did watch your video and
I was bawling my great but that one
thing that you said where you're like it
wasn't meant to be but it was meant to
happen that's like like highlight that
and bold and like place this put it on a
t-shirt put this on your relationship
like yeah I like that um like we're all
a family still but cuz you know like you
were joking before about picking sides
yeah but she was afraid that you guys
were all abandoned her and I'm all like
no I don't want anyone to do that
especially cuz there's nothing really
wrong that pattern it's just we didn't
match
not like one person from ago and over
not at all glad that this didn't end up
nasty yeah I mean like it could have
gotten a lot worse and I'm really glad
you guys hit it this way very amicable
divorce I'm glad that you don't feel
pressure now from the group because I
think that there was a lot of that
before where you're like I know that a
couple times you went for help and it
seemed like everyone's trying to keep
you guys together because it makes our
lives easier make them feel it makes us
feel better but I think that that with
that gone you're able to like kind of
just go like this is my life I'm I'm
doing my thing you know yeah yeah yep
cuz I can [ __ ] people up for sure yeah
yeah I don't know it's not bad I
completely understand why else what if I
was just like damn I don't know if this
is the right call
you know just what just came to us of
like the the spa I remember that one
night and I was the only one with
reservations everyone else was like no
you should stay together and here's how
you can work it through it all stuff but
this was like after several times of
this happening well and I think a lot of
people are you know coming from their
own relationships and they speak from
like you had just gone through healing
with Casey and so of course you're like
oh if anyone else can experience what I
experienced I'd want to help them but
you know your situations are so
different you guys had highs that are
that went to the level of like let's get
[ __ ] married and let's dedicate a
wire to each other and [ __ ] they didn't
have that and so it's just a completely
different thing that they yeah I think
the main thing is that you guys have
been in relationships like us before so
you're able to identify that or other
people that haven't really been through
that they are just only speaking from
the relationship that they're in at the
moment saying that we got through this
you guys can too but it's very different
because I think it's it once you've been
in it and you guys everything that
you've said about the past relationship
it's very similar to ours what you are
going through and you're like just trust
me when you get out of that you you feel
free again and you actually find love
it's a different feeling because you're
not supposed to feel this and it's what
we actually we are we aren't we we did
find love because I mean like she was
literally my first love yeah but we
weren't meant for each other yeah so
that t-shirt quote you should [ __ ]
copyright that shitty that's
give it more you can't scare it was a
lesson kid also too and I mainly say
that because I think a lot of people
feel invested in your relationship
people watching this video right now
they're probably like I've been watching
this show for years and I want them to
work out because I'm invested in a
person like I'm watching a [ __ ]
reality TV show but that's the whole
thing right you're watching two
characters together on a show and it and
it was real like you guys were very
honest about all your [ __ ] constantly
but just because we see them together
and we're like yeah that makes me feel
good doesn't mean that that makes them
feel good and that's the biggest [ __ ]
takeaway in your lives I hope and
anybody watching this in a similar
situation we made it a nightmare for
each other
dude it was pretty crazy man you guys
were not sources of positivity for each
other like you should have been if it
was a healthy relationship yeah the
biggest mark the myth the biggest part
that I understood when I woke up to it
was when when you had our little break
up and in for two weeks because
originally I I was like I didn't believe
in the breakup I didn't I thought that
we should have fought for it but I
became to agree and and I feel mutually
about the breakup now is because at that
time apart and and my mind going we're
not together now
I got a do me I'm thriving so I'm happy
I'm living I'm creating and I'm like
holy [ __ ] I forgot that life used to
feel this way and the person I'm with
should get me there and then she when
you were telling me like all in the past
several years you know you were going
down like I didn't see that until I felt
it and I went oh [ __ ] this relationship
was bringing me into a really dark place
that I had no idea that I was in and
then for you to know so then now that
you can breathe because we're living
together but we're not together so that
that's been lifted and you can breathe
now it's like oh [ __ ] this is the right
thing to do yeah yeah I feel like just
you're thriving to like came hey [ __ ]
the other day all like cute like bring a
dress and so that us being happy not
together that's a huge sign to me yeah
but I'm sad though cuz it didn't work
yeah I think it's not like I'm [ __ ]
having a blast you know yeah but you
learned like so much yeah so I'm
focusing on that yeah yeah [ __ ] I
haven't thought and then I forgot it is
he kept talking no they would have
worked out bingo
[ __ ] and that's why I'm like
thank God we're not together anymore and
it's a big change oh sorry you thank god
no you didn't say anything go ahead
oh no I noticed a big change in you too
it's very rare for me to like one-on-one
talk with the girls cuz I keep to myself
so much but then just texted me you were
talking like just regular girls I'm like
wow justice in a really good mood and it
made me really happy and then I was just
like oh [ __ ] hey we're talking this is
awesome like not in a group setting but
we're actually like friends and you're
opening up and you're talking more and
stuff like that it's it I noticed a
difference in you and I feel like this
is better for the both of you it's
better to be happy separate than
miserable together no matter how bad you
guys want to be I feel like our
relationship was a little bit of so we
kind of came in and we put like the ball
and chain on each other but then I feel
like the purpose of that was so that we
could learn a [ __ ] ton of stuff about
ourselves yeah and so we were locked in
and and imprisoned but we were forced to
face ourselves and face our inner demons
things that no one else had made us like
really dig deep down and look at but now
it's kind of like we're released from
prison but we we still had to go through
that sentence and but it's still it's
just very positive so that's just how I
see it we were in prison we were making
each other not a good version of
ourselves but at the same time we
learned so much that now we come out as
better people so yeah yeah I agree it's
fine do you know you went to jail
actually learn something yeah we
actually got to be your cellmate he's
gonna give me creepy diems um yeah I'm
not even checking it I just looked at it
because I get some from people that I've
like accepted before like yeah I'll
chitchat like with the girls mostly but
then I look at it and some people are
like hey don't listen to all those horny
guys that are gonna be in your DMS now
and I'm like bro you got your
you're one of them set up different
Jessica different that's the thing
though because no matter who you guys
are with next like at least there'll be
a fan in that's Jose the fan dater right
the fans are not safe Joe is gonna plow
through every [ __ ] fan of the state
every single one I will not be dating
any fans if you know your bad dream come
true if you're a fan tonight you're a
fan success story Jess what are you
talking about that's true that's true if
you guys want to see it that way sure
you got the fan like you're the patreon
like top of the that's right it was that
a quite a cost
[Music]
[Music]